alright guys bang bang I have my friend
Cindy here are you ready to do this yes
ready
alright you uh you got a whole bunch of
stuff that you've done in your life
let's just start from the beginning
let's get to your background and then
we'll get to a fun stuff
yeah we're just start out ah wait how
far back do I go where were you born
sure okay so I'm from upstate New York
like blue-collar town you were either
Irish or Italian if you were on my
streets and you know Kodak factory type
workers and and I had an exceptionally
adventurous dad who moved us from
Rochester to the Fiji Islands because
naturally that's a natural move and that
started really what I would say is my
conditioning for him where I ended up in
life because he every few years we would
move I moved every year from the fourth
grade through my senior year of high
school it conditioned me to be really
comfortable being uncomfortable and
that's that's the journey to
entrepreneurship not that I went there
right away
I actually I've always loved businesses
I was a student of business and I had
one really instrumental professor or
business professor who made me do
special assignments and report to her
every week on a business a company I had
studied and out of that I made a
decision when I got into college I went
to school in DC small Catholic school
Marymount and I said I'm gonna go work
for fortunes most of my company that was
it like I'm just gonna go learn from the
best I will take that wherever it could
have been in aerospace it could have
been in whatever it happened at the time
to be Merck which is a pharmaceutical
company so I applied I got the job
and then I realized the hell if I fit in
a big environment and they're probably
fortunes most of marks they had a great
PR department and I'm no one's listening
to me and I'm not making a contribution
at that time my big brother went to work
for startup and you know what were these
startups this is like the beginning of
the dot-com boom
and went to work first startup and I'm
watching him and I'm thinking holy crap
but he's getting to do all these cool
things
they're like testing that you know he's
doing all these things he's never done
before they listen to him and he has
skin in the game and actually I got a
chance we're gonna IPO so I got a chance
to participate in friends and family I
had no money no money so for a year I
would every day for lunch I would eat a
bowl of white rice but I could get for a
buck and I would save money and I don't
have much but when I at the end of that
year I put all this money in on this IPO
and overnight I made money and I was
like that is what I'm gonna go do and I
quit work and I went to work for a small
company and then I just kept going
smaller until I started it for myself I
loved it what was the original ideas
when you went out to actually start the
first company yeah what were you doing
was kind of the thought process behind
you you always wanted to do it but like
what was the actual genesis of it you
know what I was sick of creating value
for others that I wasn't participating
in myself
that's the like Cliff Notes version but
I had gotten to a place in my career
where I was you know going in and
helping organizing companies either for
IPO or you know we were sort of
packaging it for sale so I really kind
of had gotten a lesson and what does it
take to put together a company the right
way and then how am I not doing this for
myself and I had enough years that there
was enough of a track record of
credibility that you know it was still
ballsy as hell I mean look at me I don't
fit the part to invest in for a
pharmaceutical
CEO but I thought the hell with that I
can go find some science and I can take
the people like me who exist in these
environments they're you know high
achievers but they're totally uninspired
like this is an industry that I love for
what it does I don't love how they get
it done and so I'm thinking all right
that's my hypothesis like can I get
these people put them together well you
know what I
called it slate clean slate doing it on
my own terms like I really call it that
for that reason click these people
together we got an asset that was the
only long-acting testosterone fda
approved only long-acting testosterone
for men and in four years we've built it
to the second most prescribed among
neurologists and it was really that DNA
yeah how does that work so I think a lot
of people don't understand the
pharmaceutical industry and kind of the
connection between there's science that
goes on actually developing the drugs
getting them approved and then there's a
whole other part of the business of you
gotta get the word you actually have to
explain to doctors and those prescribing
why this has value why it's different
all that maybe talk a little bit about
those two parts of the business well you
know it is like the great mystery isn't
it like health care in general and I
will say like I'm in an industry that I
used to say we were one rung up the
ladder from tobacco companies not like
same level I mean let's be honest for
people who are watching like they hate
Pharma that's their perception from the
media but you know what we hate in the
light of day we depend on in the dark of
night if our children are sick we depend
on in this moment I actually think this
moment is an extraordinary moment for
appreciation of innovation so you know
from a pharma company perspective there
is one this extraordinarily long process
of research and development to get a
product to approval we will lose
billions of dollars on a bet that
something will work that is a rigorous
process all regulated blah blah blah
once you've got that approval you now
have to educate the market we all know
like you can't turn on the TV and not
see a drug ad but you know most of that
behind the scenes is really going in and
educating a clinician base and my first
company slate actually had an asset that
was FDA approved already it hadn't been
really marketed and so my mission was
intact
and actually to educate the market and
get the word out on so I built an
organization that was dominantly you
know in field folks that called on
doctors around the country
colleges specifically yeah so I could
say this cuz I know you well enough
you're one of the best marketers I know
absolutely world class at it and so it's
funny to me that you started out with
the testosterone drug because you were
actually better known for not helping
men but for helping women how do you go
from slate to sprout so can I tell you
the craziest thing is I've kind of been
at this for a long time so when I bought
that product what was so interesting it
was made by this brilliant formulator he
owns a patent in our industry for
extended these products he never
marketed it he's like a he's like a bad
scientist who invents these great
concoctions but it wasn't his dream to
to commercialize it and what what it was
being used for was women that wasn't
what it was approved for it was approved
for men with low testosterone but
because we had never come with a
solution for women people were using it
what's called off-label like off of what
it's indicated for and I thought this is
crazy but I it started my like awareness
if you will around how prevalent this
issue is for women and the lengths which
they would go to address it so here I am
building my company slate you know we're
not that it wasn't really hard and if
you can t like really hard but we
finally hit our stride
you know the curve started to look like
this and I'm going to all of these
scientific meetings and the biggest
conversation is about finally there's
gonna be one for women like we have a
beat on the science for what it is a
truly unlocks desire for women the
answer is not to master lies women by
giving them testosterone the answer is
to address what's going wrong which is
for women a neurochemical imbalance and
so that was my radical moment when I'm
watching the science I'm watching every
big company with way better resources
than me look at an extraordinary market
opportunity and walk away and that's
when I decided to walk in and I pulled
off the profitable business and men what
why did they want to walk away well
actually before we go into that let's
about just the sciences ups I think a
lot of people to understand so first of
all we're talking about sexual desire
yeah there's men's sexual desire and
women and the science shows that those
are two very different things maybe
describe just the difference between the
two and then we can talk about kind of
what you did to navigate this yeah so
you know when we look at sex desire gets
the party started right we have desire
we hopefully become aroused we orgasm I
hope and there's no pain present that's
how you really study sex but for women
you know what we had been doing is
saying like hey it works in men let's
see if it works in women which is
honestly pervasive across medicine not
just in this category but for women what
we have learned from brain scan imaging
and if you look at the world of Medicine
in the last two decades probably our
greatest discoveries have come from the
ability to do PET scans functional MRIs
so we knew from brain scan imaging that
if you put a woman in an MRI who
something like the switch went off she
used to want it she doesn't want anymore
like she knows it has changed versus a
woman's totally happy with the evidence
load desire exposing erotic cues their
brains light up totally differently
totally differently and so what we knew
is there's a neurochemical basis we're
very animalistic when we have sex we
basically I call we close all the tabs
in the brain we shut everything off to
enjoy the experience for a huge
percentage of women they can't shut it
off there's been a disruption and the
balance of these chemicals that allow
that to happen and that's where their
desire basically leaves the room and for
me that was so compelling so compelling
because if you sit and you talk to
somebody who's going through this it's
not just affecting them in the bedroom
it's affecting them in all aspects of
their life did I answer your question no
absolutely and so as you saw this and
there was a big difference there between
men and women yeah so laid off and
starts probably we talked a little bit
about the transition between the two
companies yeah so you know for slate
slate was a testosterone product that is
often used for male libido or
variety of symptoms if their
testosterone goes off and for me like
the calling was finally getting the
first woman at the time I did that time
I sold slate there were 25 fda-approved
drugs for men and not a single one for
women 25 there were 26 by the time I
finally crossed the finish line and we
could talk about how different that path
was for the little pink pill versus the
little blue pill but from a transaction
perspective you know when I sold it's
funny slate very few people even talked
about my first business late and yet I
really think that's where I earned the
stripes right that was the real first
lesson of putting it together myself and
when I got a beat on this this science
out of Germany I spent a year exploring
it it was inside of slate I actually
sprouted out of slate one day before I
sold sleep and I sold slate because you
know I'd gotten it to a place where it
was natural
you know acquisition target they could
take it to the next level and I needed
frankly the money for my shareholder
base to take this on for women it was
pretty pretty incredible well are you
allowed to say how much you sold the
first one for I'm not but we'll call it
hundreds of millions so my point is it
wasn't a small sale this was not a oh I
just happened to find someone down the
street this was a pretty big deal and
then obviously you then take a lot of
those investors on another journey with
sprout talked a little bit about kind of
that original idea of just like let's go
solve this problem for women ends up
becoming worth many more hundreds of
millions of dollars and so being in the
in the billions but you know if I really
I I think I was called to it a little
bit like for me as a woman in this space
first one was such an unusual bird that
I'm a female CEO in pharma then put me
as a female CEO in sexual health and I'm
running a company for men and when I
sold it off I really turned around to my
shareholder group and I said I made you
a lot of money now give me some of it
back and we're gonna go again and and
they did
I think they did because you know they
had seen me in action and what I had
built was slate what else I think they
knew just how deeply like I felt this
that we had to do it it was a radical
bet it's completely binary right I was
either at my feet is controlled by the
FDA I had to get this through the FDA I
was gonna win big or lose big and and it
was such a process to go through that
you know slate was there was a group
that we made 40 X their money like slate
is the story of I maxed out all my
credit cards I hid when the phone rang
because they were calling me like you
know it was the real kind of first
version of startup and then sleep you
can tour in sprout excuse me became this
like Phase two that felt very
straightforward to me like I knew I had
to go out and do a very specific
double-blind placebo control you know
there's a very straight path for science
what was crazy about that is when I went
on that path and I did everything that I
was supposed to do the FDA rejected me
has a bad day right what was their logic
for rejecting the first time yeah yeah
you know honestly that the answer was
well you know we think the benefits are
modest and therefore no to any risk and
like if you think about it so in
medicine and I I would say in life like
everything comes down to benefit risk
right benefit risk which feels very
objective but it's totally subjective
because if we don't assign any value to
something then we'll never take the risk
and what was happening is let's be
honest we do not value women's pleasure
for 20 years we have turned on the radio
or television and we have been told
subconsciously that men's sexual
pleasure matters viagra cialis levitra I
can keep going and going and going you
still hear these ads today there's huge
businesses built on this premise we
values or sexual performance for
and four women were like because they
can have sex whether or not they want it
really is that I mean is that right when
we know scientifically that we can help
women who have a neurochemical issue
that we would actually just say like
does it matter if they have sex like a
few more times a month the answer is if
it matters to her it's her call and I
think that's where it really ignited me
you know from the standpoint of very
proud or scientific package with 13,000
women that we studied I'll give you
context average new drug approval in the
u.s. is 760 patients with 13,000 let's
talk about a huge dataset viagra that's
a good comparator viagra had about 4,000
viagra was perceived to meet such an
important unmet medical need they got
fast tracked through the FDA and
approved within six months the
prevalence of women who deal with lo
frustrating low libido is the same as
IDI it took me six years in the same
queue so you go the first time they
reject you yeah when you hear that news
they said it in the letter or a phone
call what a fax okay but what is your
reaction when you get that fax okay so I
got a call I had just landed I'm based
in Raleigh and I just landed back at ru
and I sat down and like didn't move for
two hours I was I was paralyzed I'm like
I did all the work I met all the end
points this is statistical significance
and a double-blind placebo-controlled
trial
and I i sat down and I thought and
honestly this was going through my head
what the hell am I gonna tell my team
and they were yeah we were small but
they were so committed we had worked so
hard and I went into the offices on a
Friday and I like got everybody around
the glass table topspin in my office and
I said I said listen here's what we just
learned and I don't have any answers I
you know everybody needs to go home
this weekend and work on my resumes like
it's completely within their control so
that weekend I like went home I cried it
out if I'm honest I woke up the next day
I went back got on email and I went back
and read the letters of all the women
who had written me who knew I was doing
this saying thank you for letting me
know I'm not alone thank you for doing
this I'm losing my marriage over this
this matters to me and one woman wrote
me who had been watching this has she
been in our clinical trials and she said
I need to meet you and she was close by
so I went to meet her I went to get a
coffee with her and I got to tell you
like when I walked in the coffee shop we
didn't know each other and never seen
her before I knew it was her like she
was coming across the room walking and I
was like okay type a like in charge and
that's prototypical actually for women
who have this like they're so like
highly information processing the brain
never quiets um so she comes walking
over you know it's like a first meeting
she's telling me about herself she's
built this this she runs her own
business so she's built a company she
has two beautiful boys she's showing me
pictures she's a husband she adores but
this [ __ ] is going on and what she said
to me is she said I have succeeded in
every aspect of my life other than this
and I thought if that is not the
portrait of a woman she has raised her
hand a thousand times she said hey
something's different it's changed can
he help me and she'd been patted on the
shoulder and she'd been told oh take a
bubble bath it's okay just relax and yet
we know this scientifically so I said
can I show you something popped open my
macbook I'm showing her the brain scan
studies I look at her she is crying
pouring tears and that was my moment and
I was like this is why I'm doing it
right I had to like get myself hooked
together I went in to the work on Monday
I got everybody back again around the
glass table and I said we are going to
dispute the FDA it's a moment of silence
which is we're gonna fight the
government I like yellow
and the reason I did it is because we
had the data and what we were doing is
we were not listening to women what does
it mean to dispute the FDA gotta need
med and that's possible that was
probably one of the first person can we
do that
there actually is a mechanism see if you
get a decision you know is FDA's a huge
bureaucracy like every other government
agency and you get reviewed by divisions
we happen to be reviewed by the urology
division because they had reviewed all
the sex drugs not that that's how we
work you work on the brain but in all
the sex drugs before it had been for men
so it didn't really make sense but there
who reviewed us there's a mechanism by
which you can basically take it I tease
I call the Supreme Court of the FDA it's
not literally what it is but it's really
sort of like that process that you
dispute what happened after that is they
had public meetings and I give them
credit to their credit they opened their
doors and they invited women in and like
women you know took time off work flew
across the country talked about was
going on their bedroom at a federal
agency they were remarkable and and they
came in and after three public meetings
or at the third public meeting the FDA
basically assembles an expert panel you
know of scientists from across the
country and then they put you on trial
like you present it's the craziest thing
it's like being in a courtroom nobody
can believe this is really how it
happens we literally get up we present
the FDA talks the public gets a chance
at the microphone you would not have
believed how many people were packed in
this room and and ultimately this panel
of scientific experts having heard all
of the data make a decision and they
vote like by like audience response at
that moment and I gotta tell you I can
remember I was looking at a big screen
I'm sitting in the audience I have
security around me by the way because
this I got death threats this was so
controversial and I'm holding my phone
and I'm going like this and my hand is
just shaking because that was it like
that's the moment
and they voted overwhelmingly to approve
the job that's awesome day in court well
what were you thinking when you see that
the vote goes your way
what do you jump up and start screaming
and just like throw your middle fingers
of it everybody you know what's crazy is
I can I can remember a few things from
that day and then I think I blacked out
for moments what's so funny is to read
the text from back from the day because
there were moments where people were
like oh my God we're gonna win we're
gonna win
oh my god we're going down we're going
down and it was such a roller coaster
ride but in that moment I was just so
like calm in that moment and what was so
incredible to me is the cheers that went
across the whole crowd and I get
emotional thinking about it I gotta tell
you this does not happen often
I have a federal agency and at the FDA
and Nightline came out that night and
that clip they showed was the cheers and
like the cheers were like that doesn't
happen when a drug gets approved but it
was such a win science one make no
mistake
science one but women won that day too
and that really mattered to me during
the course of it when people would get
up and people at the public mic were
supportive and hateful detractors and my
big brother was there with me and two
big brothers both were there but one was
sitting right next to me and he kept
having to like tell me you know he would
spin everything from he's like what
they're really saying is that you're
very committed but he would spin it my
dad came my whole family came um my dad
was there and I insisted on my dad he
can't sit near me
you can't cuz he was so emotional like I
couldn't take it and he sat in the back
is crazy and so you get it approved it's
this like crazy moment and then what
within 48 hours there's an even bigger
announcement what happened there yeah
so I sold it for a billion dollars up
front and a whole lot on the back end
and that was the day after you got
approved we announced it two days after
that was one
the whole week so it got approved I got
on a plane and went up to New York we
did incredible press it was so fun for
the approval because it's like we
weren't the biggest news story in the
world the day that it was approved it
was massive global news so much fun and
then literally the next morning was on
squawk box announcing that I had sold it
and I'll tell you how that materialized
when we had that public meeting where
they voted overwhelmingly to approve the
FDA that's not the FDA's final decision
that's the decision the panel has given
them but the whole world knew they're
getting approved so it takes a few more
you know it was like a couple months
before they gave the the final the day
that happened not vote the big companies
came knocking on my door and there were
three and so like do they call you do
they text you to email you they they I
don't know I think they all emailed me I
am gonna think about that it was the the
emails started coming in like hey we'd
love to come to Raleigh and visit with
you and those stories were crazy you
know I can think about getting into the
room there was there was one suitor that
came in we went we were at a hotel my
team was sitting with me I had printed
out like binders of all of this data and
press and everything else and the woman
I work with who is a rock star attorney
came with me that day and she's sitting
next to me she's like got all the
binders but they're so big she's like
put them down on the floor and they make
us an offer and they totally lowball us
200 million was the offer and and so
they say you know it's very dramatic
they give this big speech on how they're
gonna take such good care and it's unit
Iran it really dollars and they're like
we're gonna let you think about it and
they walk out of the room so I'm sitting
there looking at all my team and they're
sort of look at me and I'm like all
right when they walk back in five
minutes get up walk out the door and I'm
like five minutes get up out the door so
they come back in and I'm like we are
really so flattered but we're gonna go
it alone thank you so much
and literally the whole team gets up
walks out the door in the lawyer who see
next to me Josephine is like she's like
pointing like and she's waving it really
like I'm like get out go so we get out
of the room and when I said to her she
said why do we leave all the signers I'm
like because that will make them call us
that they now have a reason right and so
sure enough like literally we were the
hotel is across the street from our
offices we were literally walking into
our office and I got a phone call and
they're like we have your binders I'm
like oh that's fine you keep them there
for you and that like allowed the door
to still be open and that conversation
to keep going I love that and so
obviously you end up selling it for a
billion dollars in cash which I think a
lot of people when they hear a number
like hey I saw my coming for a billion
dollars most deals are stock and equity
and earn out it's like that was just
cash and so I asked every single person
what do you do when you see a billion
dollars wired right like you know I just
imagine you look in the bank account and
there is one billion dollars what is the
reaction you know and I have a weird
relationship with money if I'm being
totally honest uh I got out the next one
I went to work like and I'm not saying
that I wasn't you know so proud of it
and but it's really like it didn't
change anything about what I still
wanted to do and I just got up and I
went to work I have a guy that is my
financial advisor and and I have I laugh
I have told this story but it was not
that long ago and he came into the
office and he basically said well you
live in the same house you drive the
same car and then he looks at me he goes
I'm pretty sure you were wearing that
we're good
it was unbelievable but the work wasn't
done
you know the work was just like gettin
started forgetting it to market so it
was it was there were there were little
moments reflection I will share Gayle
King had me on CBS this morning
to announce the approval and you know
that was the pressure sitting in the
green room at CBS this morning and and
getting on set and then the next day we
were squat Fox announced the sale and
she wrote me a little email and she said
oh sure you couldn't have said that on
my program and she's like you are a
badass and I still have it on my desk
like that is it was so flattering so
moments like that really you know made a
huge impression on me for sure and so
since then you've gone on to do
investing pink.you bader
a bunch of things to kind of help other
women Wow or women focus businesses
maybe talk a little bit about some of
the other stuff you did and then we'll
get to the really fun part where where
you may or may not get the drug back so
you know what's crazy is I sold the
business I thought I was gonna stay
Clark maybe it's a classic story of you
know founder mama bear not getting along
with new acquirer I was invited to leave
I just say and I had to like sit on the
sidelines and you know check myself they
paid a billion dollars for it know that
I still would be there and cheering it
on but also figure out like what's next
and it's extraordinary right like if you
can have any possibility or you have no
possibility what do you choose and for
me I think that what was so clear is I
had literally lived a front row lesson
in what it means to advocate for
yourself and for other women and look
I'm not actually somebody who talks a
lot about you know was was I was I in a
male-dominated industry where there
crazy moments and you know in a room
where you were marginalized or whatever
sure but I was gonna get through it like
I understand it it's very different for
me to like experience that at a map
scale and so I thought well the hell
like I need to invest in disruption like
I don't only want to disrupt in the
market for technologies that we need in
women's health I want to disrupt a
mindset of who has the next
billion-dollar idea and that matters to
me and pomp knows some of the profile of
women that I invest in and you know
about this great engineer but she's
gorgeous
like she's 510 she's blonde she's Texan
and let's be honest like when she shows
up on Sand Hill Road you're sort of like
okay you know like it's very hard to
actually get beyond that but she's gonna
sell her company for hundreds of
millions of dollars and like the next
time somebody who looks like her walks
in the room we all reach for our wallet
that that is like part of the design and
so it's been wonderful for me to get to
invest in things that not only I think
our groundbreaking first I mean I love
the big challenges take the big
crazy-ass wing right that it has a
little probability of going through I
think we're pretty good at that and
there's often like catalysts and social
change as well that just matter to me
flexible pregnancy test yeah so I can
say this because I know you well enough
and I asked you one time
behind closed doors you could have lied
you know all through your teeth to the
public but behind closed doors I said to
you why are you doing this and this is
when you were investing and kind of
really you know pressing the gas on the
pink you bader and you said to me to
make women [ __ ] rich I remember just
walking out of there being like Cindy is
a [ __ ] bad-ass she was so
controversial when somebody was me when
you first started like well what's the
mission what are you doing a little oh
and you try to explain then I'm like to
make me really [ __ ] rich and you know
we should all of us should want that
made the best man or woman win
just let's be let's be if they give it a
fair shake let's not overlook an idea
because we think it's niche because it
affects half of the population I'll take
that idea
and I mean that really does happen just
I'm getting and by-the-numbers is how
you bear it out right 4% 4% of
investment dollars go to women's health
research that's crazy and so those are
the things that really ignite me and it
is about picking people who are going to
get to a finish line like I'm like I'm a
I'm a early seer I think you're a
founder CEO or your forever CEO I'm a
founder CEO I like to build it I like to
build it from scratch and create enough
value that somebody else comes in and
fires it and that's really the profile
that companies I'm taking on - yeah
you've got a team that was with you
slate sprout investing what you're doing
now and they all stick with you and
you've got everything from embarrassing
funny nicknames for them to the quirky
culture you wear pink every day kind of
all these different elements that you've
built like talk a little bit about just
building that culture and how you've
kept a team together for so long through
multiple iterations of the work you guys
are doing you know culture was the the
agenda for sleep I mean honest to god
that was the most important piece of it
for me is how do you build a culture of
ownership let me be specific about it so
for me right why would you leap and do
it for yourself you want skin in the
game you want a piece of what you create
and I've got the recipe for everybody to
be wildly successful in building your
business treat everybody like the owner
of the company give them a piece of what
they get out of bed every day and go to
work and do for you and I think we have
you know an outreach it actually creates
an environment of what I'd call
constructive irreverence right if
everyone's the owner like they're
challenging they're challenging and I'm
not the only person trying to hold
people accountable it's really that
everyone holds each other accountable
because we're gonna cross the finish
line and when I look to my left
you better deserve to be there and and I
really think that has been a piece I
so pick we are total misfits lots of you
know entrepreneurs will say this but I
have always seen myself as a misfit and
I am definitely attracted to other
people who are misfits
and I think that kind of culture creates
this extraordinary quirkiness and
individuality that has you achieve
incredible things when I got into big
companies early in my career what was so
counterintuitive to me is that they were
trying to beat you into sameness one way
this is our way here's how we do it
you have to processes and companies but
you're you are missing the boat if
you're taking that away from people so
my culture is really simple I say you
make six choices to come work for me and
we really and I hire against it I fire
against it I incentivize against it and
they sound like you know I don't know
one of my choices is quirky what the
hell does that mean how do you interview
for that I don't say to people like are
you quirky yes okay check that box like
you're really finding that individuality
but I think it's ownership mindedness
its boldness its quirkiness its that
they're all learners like we are never
so arrogant to think that we know at
best we constantly go and learn from
others especially outside of our
industry where we truly are family we're
very loyal to one another I think you
know we can do this behind doors but
when we walk out were locked arms
against the world and we're appreciative
and I think even in the darkest moments
of and there were look there were
moments when were hanging on by a thread
like we were gonna be shut down the next
day there was still like an underpinning
of like a pre marveling at what we were
trying to do and I think that has gotten
us through all of these years yeah pop
knows nurse ratchet she's there with me
do I need I don't even need to describe
why this is her nickname but you know
ratch has been with me for 17 years like
she's she can tell all the craziest
stories you know that we've had but like
there's something about that yeah
we'll say you know when I sold this
company and I cheered them on from the
sidelines the most important things that
my people stayed when they were gone and
they moved on in their lives and I got
it back I picked up the phone and I'm
like hey and like their husbands their
wives their kids are like oh no oh wait
Cyndi's Collin what's gonna happen mom
dad you know whoever and and I was like
hey we're gonna do this again and they
drop what they were doing they came back
to do it all right so you sold the
business for a billion dollars in cash
you make your investors yourself
everyone's walking away very happy yeah
they take the drug and maybe don't do
what everyone thought was possible with
it and now you are sitting here and
somehow you have to drug and they gave
you cash and now you are running a
business with that drug again how does
that happen
right there's only one other person that
I know so I'm gonna pick on a little bit
Doug loved sold Lending Tree yeah they
then grew it and if I remember correctly
they basically sold it it fell like 75
80 percent in value he went bought it
back or he actually paid for it and then
went and grew it again and so that is a
story that's happened before I've never
seen somebody sell the business and then
basically the acquirer says keep the
cash get your truck back head like it
leaves and here we'll give you a loan so
you don't have to be distracted with
fundraising yeah you know it's an
extraordinary story and you get smarter
to go along so I'll tell you how that
happened well first of all they I could
not have written this movie like the way
that it played out and maybe it's the
first drug for female pleasure was gonna
have the most crepe must insane story
not only our story and fighting the
government but then you know you win and
and it's really like the on hers dream
come true we were 35 people when we
created a billion dollars worth of value
35 of us and you know they were gonna
marched across the globe and make it
affordable in ways that we really
couldn't at that moment in time they
take it they're gonna keep me in all the
team invite me to leave
three months later they dismantle my
entire team they put it on the shelf so
what happens is we announce a sale you
know it takes a while before those
clothes on October 1 it closed that was
in 2015 11 days later they got a letter
from the Department of Justice and there
was an investigation because they hadn't
disclosed his pharmacy relationship that
they had no one knew neither
sophisticated investors or anybody else
knew and and the world went boom and the
truth is we were the last thing in the
door I was not happy not having if I'm
in the middle of about going to a launch
and and so I become a liability I'm gone
then the total team is gone because
they're trying to save the core business
which is burning to the ground this that
the day that we sold to them like they
were the darling they were 260 a share
they traded down into the teens so the
truth is it just got deprioritize it was
punished off and we have fought so hard
to finally women got one on the board
and the women who needed it couldn't get
it and I used to mystery shop it like
I'd go to Target can I get it no it's
not available crazy so they got a new
CEO they forgot her CEO total turmoil
and he was on the job about two weeks
he's a lovely man and I sat down and I
said can I get it back
like we just paid your billion dollars
for I think this has a ton of value I'm
like well good I'm glad you remember
that cuz my shareholders do as well and
not in a threatening way but like for
real there's a lot of value here and our
transaction was structured so here's
where I got smarter when I sold slate
I got money out front and then I got
money on the back end I participated in
royalties mailbox money for years which
was great it but it was governed by
boilerplate language best efforts Clause
classic legal investor words class well
actually when you do that what you
realize is well your best efforts and my
best efforts are different so like you
know as a founder you sit there like oh
they should be doing this or not doing
and you like have angst about it so when
I sold sprout I wrote the same deal we
had all of this money coming on the back
end but it was governed by very specific
performance obligations and they weren't
outrageous they were like how much money
we spend on marketing how much money we
spend on field education not another
nother dot they weren't meeting any of
them so when they blew me off I sued
them and the court of Delaware in
exchange for dropping the lawsuit I got
the company back and I kept the billion
dollars and got a loan to get started I
win they win they get a participation in
royalties but not a bad deal so what
have you done so far because now we're
sitting now you're sitting here with the
drug back you've got the company to kind
of get a second shot at it I think you
would say that you are not only a
billion dollars richer but also a
plethora of knowledge and experience in
what you can go do now so what's kind of
the plan and where are you guys that I
got to tell you the best part like you
know in my world it's a pink line you
know silver lining but the pink lining
is I had to sit on the sidelines for a
few years and I had to go all right what
would I be doing what's changed well how
would I be smarter about it and so I I
was sitting there kind of doing that
class if you will in my head for a
couple years and when I got the product
back
look it is hard it wasn't like I got it
back and it was here I got back and I
was here because really did do nothing
was something that was the biggest news
story in the world damage is it because
people don't know the inside story so
like their perception is well that
didn't go anywhere the reality was how
could it have nobilis marketing him it
wasn't stocked in any pharmacies across
the United States is insane
so we have fixed all the supply chain we
have gotten it you know ready and we've
imagined this is a thing I'm probably
most proud of we've imagined a path in
which women can have this conversation
from the comfort of their couch privacy
other house doctor licensure state
doesn't require physical exam so
telemedicine
to think about that we were ahead now in
covin world all of us are talking about
telemedicine as a future medicine
thankfully we got a jump start on it and
and it shifts to your doorstep you know
like an Amazon like experience and so
it's been fascinating I'll tell you it
took me a while like I had to go back
and work with the FDA on some of the
labeling things that were you know
should have been modified based on some
data I had to get all the sly chain set
but this year really it's just this year
we turned on real advertising and like
the first ad ran on Howard Stern and
like I sat in my car and cried like a
baby because it was it's been ten years
to get to that moment and so I think
everybody will start to hear a lot more
about it I mean than kovat hits right
and Here I am again like it's the my
story is like right when you think it's
you know it goes sideways and for me
like a lot of that brand awareness I
mean that I don't have metrics yet on
and conversion and everything else like
you go alright I'm holding like I got a
hold and hang on to my hang on to my
people who are the most important
component of the business and then we'll
figure it out from here yeah talk a
little bit about the telemedicine stuff
because I think people are starting to
see you know before this happened it was
not a little bit more popular anoxic
Ovid it's like the talk of the town just
how do you see that whole part of the
industry well look I'll sound like such
a VC type person which I'm not I'm
totally an operator but let's be honest
let's think about like investments that
have done phenomenally well of late like
we think about that intersection of
digital consumer what were people
chasing they were chasing the Dollar
Shave club's the worried Parkers like
all of those I think that the next
frontier and everyone is chasing the
intersection of digital in healthcare
and telemedicine was really born out of
helping people in remote areas who
couldn't get to doctors but let's be
real about stats it takes 29 days on
average to see your primary care doctor
forget your specialist 29 days to get
into a primary care doctors office we
all know what that experience
is like sitting with the clipboard and
like you know is somebody sneezing next
to you and everything else for so many
conditions we don't actually need a
physical exam we can have this exchange
by a video we can have a phone exchange
we could even have a digital exchange
when you have my medical history
it is telemedicine is the future of
Medicine 100% it is more cost-effective
it meets our schedules and how we all
consume today we're not going to
tolerate taking the time for that and it
actually I think in many ways I've been
through so many of these experiences now
as I tested telemedicine it's so
comprehensive you know you can go online
and do your vision test to get your
glasses it's brilliant so I'm really
such a huge fan of that and I think
that's you know that's here to stay in
an epic way and probably while it has
been here we are all slow as humans to
change habits
kovin has sort of forced that change
yeah
and how much of this is dependent on the
doctors and the regulations kind of
complying with it versus those things
already allowed for this and it was just
a technology barrier yeah so there's a
they have been a little lessened right
now in this moment in time you know
everything from everything is governed
by regulation obviously in this industry
and while you can get a D through a
telemedicine experience I have no like
it's a wall between me and them they
they literally see on my site you are
leaving us to go to another company I
went to a bunch of telemedicine
companies and said look here's my
hypothesis women would prefer to not
necessarily bring this up in person but
to have a private conversation if you
will educate all of your you know
clinicians in your network like I will
shoot send them your way and we have a
variety of them that we work with but
there's really you know FaceTime was
built with HIPAA compliance so really
the technology is there to protect our
information it's really been more of
like a habit change of in my mind of
consumers or even an understanding you
would think when you say telemedicine
it's an
to italy obvious what it is but so many
people say to me what is that like what
the hell are you talking about so I
think it's really still a very new
concept for people but once you do it
it's hard to go back
I'm not saying done to your regular
visits with your physician but I have
been saying to a lot of my friends right
now
I mean look physicals everything else
you need to show up annuals for women
but a lot of my friends are like oh well
I have an appointment with my doctor but
I guess I'll just schedule it before you
know September I'm like no way call
their office get on their website seeds
are doing telemedicine like doctors are
is my heart there are often small
business owners think about it there one
two people in a practice often not
necessarily owned by the hospital system
and they're struggling right now because
nobody's walking through their doors
like this is a great way I think to even
be supportive of health care
professionals right now for sure
speaking of supportive you have taken
Hollywood by storm in a way and you have
a campaign along with a number of other
women called women on top maybe tell us
a little bit about that yeah well first
I have to tell you we all wear sweaters
that say women on top like in solid I've
seen them I've seen them all over the
Internet
and and I have to say I was leaving LAX
the last time and I was going through
security and the the guard on the other
side is looking at me and she was like
women on top she goes girl you know that
can mean two things right all right I
know just I love that reaction yeah I
when would Eva Longoria was you know
coming out of the ivy and like that I
loved the paparazzi or photographing her
and everything else and then they're
like women on top I like your sweater
but here's what it is
so to me it's really been remarkable to
get to know all these women on top women
that we look to who are truly dedicated
to putting other women on so that's what
it is and it was born out of this
conversation around Addie and sprout and
little bit of my story we had a very
funny video release through the Funny or
Die crowd a bunch of female comedians
took this on they were like you know we
can use humor to poke at the absurdity
that we don't talk about this for women
despite the fact that you know we've
talked about it for men for so long and
by the way it's good for everybody
just guys not to this is not male/female
this is like universal and and they did
a premiere in New York and LA and it
caught fire and I think it just
resonated with people a couple things
and that is you know this story of you
can take on you can take on an injustice
and win and there were two right not
only the FDA fight but I think also the
what happened with the company and and
it's really about like everything that I
do at the pink ceiling and in the pink
you bader it's just putting power in
women's hands and you know the women who
have surrounded me that's the coolest
part right if you think about it I would
say in so many ways including fighting
the government I took the road less
traveled the remarkable part of that is
you will be awed by who comes and walks
alongside of you and a lot of that has
been you know Hollywood actresses and we
go into you know they're they'll say
come over and meet all my friends and
talk about what you do and inevitably
then we all start talking sex and it
becomes a confessional that's very
that's very fun but they're ready to
like own it in a different way and and
for me obviously I am passionate about
women's health and but also sexuality
and and I think I'm unafraid to talk
about this in a conversation we're
having about wellness and god bless we
find there we're talking about mental
wellness and physical wellness right you
can't turn on and not caecilia wellness
well the third aspect of that is sexual
wellness and it's going to be a you know
almost thirty billion dollar industry by
2025 and I'm glad that we we we broke
the ceiling and we open that door and I
think that there's so many things that
have come
through on that and a conversation ready
to be had because it's part of your
overall if you will moxie in power of
how you show up in this world so when
the movie gets made
who plays Cindy you have to pick this I
can't make it who would you want to play
you oh well you know there's a adore
Sandra Bullock I always have adored
Sandra Bullock so like I mean come on
and and I do laugh always at the Reese
Witherspoon because I did a whole like
tweet series on everything I need to
know about business I learned from
Legally Blonde and you know the the pink
pumps that I wear pink all the time you
know that was born out of well first I
love pink it's hard to find a childhood
photo of me while I'm not in pink and it
was born out of the fact that when I did
this people would say oh the little pink
pill that's so cute
that's so cute and and I thought what so
you know pink is a little bit of the
transition from underestimated to
unapologetic they didn't see me coming
but I wasn't gonna give up who I was and
I would show up at the FDA in blazing
hot pink and at that same lawyer I told
you stories that would be like can you
just wear a sensible black pantsuit and
I would show up in the pinks would just
keep getting brighter because we were
going to talk about it and so you know I
think about the Legally Blonde there is
a little bit of that in all of us male
or female right we all have been
underestimated in the room overlooked
you know in some way and I think that
that mine shaft from underestimated to
unapologetic is a really defining moment
for all of us a little bit what's the
one thing you would go back and tell
yourself at the start of your career
that you know now what's the best piece
of advice you could have given yourself
damn I wanted to say like my personal
self I would say have more sex but let
me do my professional self what would I
tell myself I I think it probably comes
down to the only thing you will ever
regret
that you didn't do it sooner that's it
that's like my regrets are I should have
done that a long time ago and so you
know when your instinct your gut
instinct is there when everything inside
it's like telling you to do it do it
because you're only gonna be sad you did
it
that's nine you're gonna live through
way more pain in the interim you're
still gonna get it done eventually yeah
I love that piece of advice two glass
questions to wrap up then you get to ask
me one what is your favorite book you've
ever read I'm such a broken record but I
am like the mega fan of Purple Cow a
Seth Godin fan and I gotta tell you if
you haven't read it it's like I'm dating
myself it's really a book about
marketing you know and that why
remarkable wins why remarkable attracts
remarkable but it really for me before I
started slate was eye-opening in that
same concept of how do you stand out in
a sea of sameness and really like how do
you recruit against a purple cow
philosophy for me when somebody's
reached my desk on paper like they're
totally qualified for the job all I'm
listening for are those cues of what
makes them different in terms of how
they stand out for them to be part of
our group the the resume means nothing
the that it factor is everything a
little bit aliens
believer or non-believer okay I'm a
believer by like Association and let me
tell you what I mean by that so i am i
count mark kelly as a dear friend um
asked for not like you talk about an
incredible human being he's out there on
the risk her and I heard somebody wants
to ask him right like mark is there you
know is there life you know outside of
here and he was like why would we think
there wasn't which is the right answer
on soap for so many things in our life
you know when we're questioning the
right answers like why wouldn't we
imagine that
possibility big scary world out there
all right signing up for like to the
travel to space that's not on my bucket
list
wit all right so here's a question I
love getting people's answers would you
rather go to the depths of the ocean or
the space but you had to choose one
which one are you less fearful of the
depths of the ocean really yeah why I
because it's like the view would be
great I don't know I am the among other
like fascinating creatures I I don't
know I think I don't know I don't know
the creatures above but I do know maybe
when I'm dealing with below maybe that's
where it comes from which one would you
do uh I probably would go to space okay
not be good for any other reason than
the ocean like there's definitely stuff
down there we got no clue about like I
saw I'm sorry
that is true that must it I saw a video
feels like an octopus going through the
water is changing colors based on what
was around it you know just like I'm out
and I like I'll just go to space hope I
don't run into anybody I'm good probably
one question you have for me to to
finish up I have to one is we tell
everybody the story about when you tried
on high heels at the pink ceiling oh I
did yeah I did do that uh what was the
story we you had a party uh me Jason a
bunch of people went and thisis couture
which is a company that we had invested
in they have made the world's most
comfortable heel dolly came from SpaceX
and created this thing and what she sent
I think a pair for you to try on yeah
you refused and I think some some people
that work with you tried them on I just
want to say that pomp Adam on it was
parading it I did I don't know if I was
creating around I just need you to know
there's some secrets here that I got I
don't I don't know if I if I had paraded
around I think I've put them on and
stood on one of
but I don't know if I what's you know my
store my question for you is what's the
one thing your family gave you that
wired you for this uh thick-skinned like
without a doubt because the skin is one
of these things I'm a big believer in
the idea that you can only develop thick
skin you're not born with it and the way
you get thick skin can be through
experiences the way people treat you you
know also you can't read about it in a
book right and also I know I have to fix
it and I grew up in a family for bull
five boys total four brothers my dad was
you know classic just bust our balls
whole time and now you kind of look
around the room like actually if you've
got thick skin like you're better set
for the world than most other people and
so it's a it's funny because if you ask
me also like who the toughest person in
my family is is probably my mom mm-hmm
which like physically maybe not but like
she will send our [ __ ] packet if we
don't it'll stay in love she's
outnumbered she has to I do attribute
that I to Big Brothers you know you've
met them like they are everybody thinks
oh you're young you're the youngest and
a girl and I think they did not get that
memo like they did not they decided they
were and like here did tough and toughen
me up I have to tell one story when Tom
and I first met wait for him he showed
up in a pink convertible which I did you
know we would be friends from the moment
you pulled up but that was I can't I
don't even know what make it was was one
of these like spectacular like old
school your mom so I had a black
avalanche like a truck couldn't be more
of like a male you know oriented truck
and it was getting work on and my mother
had a pink Thunderbird convertible that
my dad had
got infer and like gotten fixed up and
he likes working on old cars in one
story but I have remember I was coming
to meet you and I'll say oh [ __ ] I got
my card struck so I was like hey mom can
I grab a car and she needed her carsick
we'll just take that one and ever
looking at it being like really and so
you have like one of two options right
if that's the situation you're and I
didn't know anything about you wearing
pink or any of this stuff and I was like
you either own it when you hide from it
and so I've rolled down the windows you
know blasted music and drove down the
street in this pink car they came to
meet you it was like I gotta show you
what's outside because you're gonna love
this of course where do you want to send
people where do you want them to go yeah
please follow me on instagram at Cindy
pink CEO you can see all of our women on
top campaign initiatives and if you want
to pitch or you know need some help with
your business it's the pink ceiling com
awesome I appreciate you doing this I
think people will enjoy it and we'll do
it again soon